which we lost in a while differentiating
investor functions right bless you
I've been looking at chain rule and then
looking at how to apply system max being
very briefly
okay now integrals is kind of like a
natural next step okay but you kind of
run into a problem because if I were to
give you a question like this right okay
you know so intuition might think you
know if I were integrating say sine X
what would that be equal to
it would be negative cos plus you're
clustered right so you're like wow
wouldn't it be cool I'm gonna be
convenient if you're a sine inverse goes
to negative cos inverse except the
problem is that's the rubbish why how do
you know because Matt that is true what
specific kind of maths is the problem
what is a what is an integral anyway
what is a primitive function if I if I
say this it's great that we just
excellent here
I should be able to go back the other
way but I should be able differentiate
this and they're gonna say leave us but
you guys need to do because it's not
even close right so this turns out to me
not one of the results which is that's
straightforward okay now I will show it
to you later on but you're not expected
to know it okay but here's the important
thing right even not knowing what this
primitive function is equal to I can
still work out a whole bunch of
integrals of the inverse trig functions
if they are definite okay because a
definite integral like if I had
boundaries to this slack for instance
zero to one okay all that is is an area
okay so even if I don't know the action
but this is gonna turn into if I can
work out that area so then under what
the actual definite interval is equal to
all right so to try and wrap their heads
around it that's what these diagrams are
for okay now I'll just give you a
warning ahead of time we did remember
what next in other words but we've done
some graphene money investing functions
okay you really need to get good at
graph you do not just like you don't
know where they're going to go and have
the domain or range changes but your
actual brow shape needs to be quite
accurate don't see why it is that's
active so let's just do this one
actually sine inverse what does it look
like okay now scale and shape it's all
gonna matter okay so if you think kind
of you know have had anyway you've been
doing it so far now is the time to stop
because of actually causing problems
later on so a little foot so please make
sure at the end points what's the
gradient line at the airport and what's
it doing at the origin it should be
going through at 45 degrees right so I'm
gonna get something like okay that's
pretty good your bet they don't to be
able to look at that okay now what's the
area I'd love to hear I'm going from LA
to one
okay so we know where that is right this
is actually all the way to the end of
the domain so if I if I put this in
boundary view that's the actual area I
fire a favorite for you initiated that's
the area from from nought to one now I'm
just a half-turn area right so even
though I don't know if yet what this
preview function is if I can compare to
Saab shape that I do know the area all
there should be fine so I want to think
about this I'll be the problem is that
it's it's curvy right but I know another
function which curves in exactly the
same way almost which I'm quite good at
working at the area off right so what
should I compare to just just regular
size right it's a sine inverse yes I'm
going to draw sine X and I'm going to
draw it in the same domain and range and
except of course it's fits around okay
now over here my rage is not to plant -
okay so that means my domain over here
is over - okay
this is just like is okay now this
diagram what is the same area what area
does this correspond soon and the answer
is yeah it's it's the area on top of the
curve if you like or the area bound
between the curve and the y axis between
them okay so here and the thing is
because this is just regular size okay
if you got given this question like a
few weeks ago you would have been able
to work it out with no regards industry
right what would you have done
yeah good so think about this shape
right if we integrate sign I'm not going
to get the green area I'm gonna get the
area underneath the fence down to the
x-axis right which is not the area I
want but it's good enough right because
if I can work out that area this is just
a rectangle okay and then I can just
take the difference okay so here's the
way that I would write it out this
integral here this is definitely - all
right what's actually equal to it it's
equal to this rectangle right which has
this area okay can you see that's length
times bread and then I subtract the area
underneath the curve now what's the
integral that corresponds to that it's
another definite integral what are its
boundaries yeah good so these are my
experience there okay and this is not
this function anymore it's this function
so it's each of other side okay so we've
kind of translated the problem into
terms and functions or a much more
capable of dealing so let's just quickly
evaluate this and this is PI on food -
what's the primitive website - close so
I actually haven't done them thinking
okay so I'm gonna get rid of the W okay
now I'll evaluate my upper and lower
bats
what's closing platitude closet yep it
comes down to the axis and cause of zero
waste that way there's actually just one
right okay so that seems like an honest
up now just very quickly I've been doing
this already
what's this actually equal to pi is big
one formal soap I love to is like one
point five seven ish so this is a bad
0.57 right does that look like it's in
the right ballpark that seem like it's
an accurate in itself it is a pretty
small area right and this whole thing is
only one unit one so I think that look
at that one
now I did say before then we don't know
what this sum what the primitive of that
is okay but you can work it out and in
fact it's it's in the same class of
question as I think I'm gonna show you
this before it's in the same classroom
question is something like this
okay now you're not expected to know
what the definite integral of sorry the
indefinite integral of that is it's not
a result you have to memorize it's not
on your table or standard integrals but
you can work it out
if the first part of the question says
do this and hence work out what the
integral is okay and I think I showed
that to some of you before I could
rehearse it again but what I want to do
instead is to do with sine inverse now I
wonder what you think the derivative
sorry the period of service might look
like what would it be close to now it's
pretty hard to guess once I give you the
form you might start thinking oh yeah
okay I think I could recognize it I'm
just gonna give you the form now we'll
prove it just so we can verify this
result that's all I'm after done okay so
instead of doing this XE DDX business
here's what I'd like you to do for Part
A of this question Oh differentiate this
function
okay that's that's what I'd like you to
do I've only written in two months
because I haven't given myself enough
space on the right hand side but the
square root of 1 minus X square plus X
sine inverse of X okay that's what I'd
like you to differentiate and hence give
me the definite integral of sine of s
okay then let's see use that result to
see if we can make sure where it
actually got the right answer here so
work out the definite integral is from
okay
so I'll give you guys a few minutes to
do that